turning of the Philippines which has
been rocked by a series of powerful
earthquakes today a quake with a
magnitude of 6.4 hit the central regions
there were no immediate reports of
casualties of major damage and it comes
a day after an earlier earthquake that
shook the country's north and left at
least 16 people dead now rescue teams
are still searching for survivors after
Monday's tremors another big relief for
rescuers as they pull the survivor out
of the rubble they've been working
around the clock since the strong tremor
on Monday but despite immense time
pressure rescuers have to proceed
carefully to avoid crushing anyone still
trapped in structure of course the
structure is big and heavy and we have
to be careful in clearing the debris
because there might be survivors so it's
hard but we are doing everything we can
this is the moment when the earthquake
struck captured on a mobile phone bought
her from a swimming pool cascading down
a building and here the aftermath
several centuries all churches have been
seriously damaged as well as some
bridges houses and roads the city of
Park located in the north and
Philippines near the capital Manila is
one of the worst hit areas one of his
residents recalled the fear she
experienced we were shocked and
terrified we weren't expecting it at all
it only lasted about 20 seconds but it
was very strong it was our first time
experiencing something like that in our
whole lives y Nami but that was not the
end of it today are not a strong tremor
hit the nation this time in the center
of the country